they hit see let the folks do Madeira
awesome politique you are an 18 year old
high school exchange student in a small
Bavarian town you've been invited on a
congressional delegation to Berlin
Germany and you are the youngest person
there by at least 30 years you're
wearing a business suit for the first
time ever you're feeling pretty good and
so you raise your hand and you ask the
congressman they hit C laugh at folks do
Medina awesome politique what are your
foreign policy goals and as the words
confidently come out of your mouth you
hear the audience gasp today I want to
speak to you about how language shapes
us and our relationships in our
globalized world people are able to
connect between far corners of this
planet and as English becomes the lingua
franca every day more and more of these
conversations are happening in a common
language but what happens when people
begin communicating in a language that
is not their own a lot gets lost in
translation a lot more than just words
our values our beliefs and our norms are
embedded in our language but it goes a
step further our language influences how
we see the world and what we think about
it by not fully appreciating the
importance of language are we short
changing relationships so as I crouched
back in those congressional chambers
with 50 sets of eyes staring at me I
wondered what did I do wrong I replayed
the words in my head
what are your foreign policy goals
couldn't figure it out
what are your four shavette
I do did the congressman I committed the
cardinal sin of all German language
learners you see in German just as in
French or Spanish there are two versions
of the second person pronoun you do and
Zi the informal and the formal I had
learned this role many times before but
I just glossed over those pages of my
textbooks I didn't understand why I
should have to address someone
differently just because they were older
than me what I didn't realize is that in
ignoring this rule I was ignoring an
important social norm of respect and
hierarchy as I address my congressman
with the informal do I offended him his
office his reputation and all 50 adults
staring at me by ignoring the importance
of language I missed an opportunity to
form a meaningful relationship now
speaking of meaningful relationships how
many of you remember the first time you
met your in-laws scary right my fiance
Alex came with me to visit my extended
family in Belgrade Serbia the city in
which I was born about a year into our
relationship the day we landed I took
him to my favorite outdoor cafe and as
he slipped in on an iced tea he asked me
so what who exactly are we meeting
tomorrow
I started town about all my aunts and
uncles I was so excited for him to meet
but he interrupted me how are you
related to all of these people
I grabbed a napkin and a pen and I
started drawing my family tree will you
see tomorrow we're gonna hang out my
mom's side of the family I love her on
and uncle basically raised her sloths
underdog and and their kids silence
sounded and then their kids me hilum me
Hilah and me let's I mean they're just
like this to us and then the next day
we're gonna have my dad's side of the
family because my grandfather my dad's
side he had four siblings and all of
them have obviously there's aunts and
uncles and then cousins and then I guess
Grand cousins I'm not really sure what
you call it many of them live in Boston
in Toronto but they're all here for the
summer and then next week we're going to
go to eastern Serbia we're gonna have my
mom's side of the family that would
grandfather had three siblings so
there's a lot of them over there as well
so as I rattled off my family tree I
realized how much was lost in
translation in Serbian I have words to
describe if my aunts and uncles are from
my maternal or paternal side if they're
related by blood or by marriage Chinese
even has words to describe the relative
birth order of your aunts and uncles but
in English I only had two words on and
uncle embedded in our language are our
values and if sharing and understanding
one another's values is one of the
bedrocks of meaningful relationships are
we missing an opportunity
Alex's immediate family means the world
to him but I couldn't imagine a world
without my Serbian version of My Big Fat
Greek Wedding
as I translated my family tree to him in
English my value of extended family and
community was lost in translation fully
understanding our values is critical if
we truly want to understand each other
are we missing an opportunity by not
fully understanding how language shapes
us whether you're navigating your
in-laws family tree or a multinational
corporations org structure you might be
able to learn something about the about
what matters to the people around you by
understanding the words they would use
to describe their worlds now I have a
question for all of you how would you
describe the following situation oh [ __ ]
sorry about that now imagine I broke the
glass how would you describe what just
happened English speakers are more
likely to say yell enough broke the
glass
whereas Spanish and Japanese speakers
are most likely to say the glass broke
itself say don't be up
how do you think the way you answer that
question
impacts the way you see the world the
cognitive scientists who ran the initial
glass experiment at Stanford found that
when a glass was broken by accident
English speakers were more likely to
remember who broke the glass than
Spanish or Japanese speakers they were
more likely to assign agency to an
individual even in the event of an
accident this has massive implications
on society our language impacts how we
see the world how we think about our
relationships to each other to our
government how we interpret financial
crises I understand that there's a
chicken and egg problem here does
language create culture or does culture
create language I am NOT going to
venture to answer that question today I
will leave that to the linguist the
simple fact is that two people can
interpret the exact same event in two
completely different ways simply because
of how they formulate their sentences by
not fully appreciating how language
shapes our worldview and that of others
are we short changing relationships so
when I think back to my 18 year old self
confidently raising my hand and
accidentally dueting my congressman I
realize how lucky I was to have offended
him then and make that mistake time and
time again I have seen how language how
our values our norms and our beliefs are
embedded in and shaped by our about a
buyer language many of us will go on to
live in a globalized world but each and
every one of us will continue to form
relationships across cultural ties so
I'd encourage you just as I did to stop
thinking about those rules as being
frustrating things you have to learn in
class to learning more of them I've gone
from seeing language as a barrier to
building relationships to see as an
opportunity to deepen them
so next time you are feeling pretty good
raising her hand I'm ready to ask that
question ask yourself first how does
language shape me and how do I want to
use it to shape my relationships
thank you